Alright, so we just got to Hollywood.
We're going to the IT Neibolt House Hollywood.
I don't know if it's like a haunted house
or just like a type of thing where you take
pictures, but we're gonna go check it out.
This is is recreation of the 29 Neibolt House
from the IT movie and we're gonna be checking
this out in a little bit.
If you guys aren't familiar with the book
IT, this is where the Lucky 7 has one of their
earliest confrontations with Pennywise.
So I'm excited to see what's in store for
us.
We're here at the side of the Neibolt house.
This is where Eddie encounters the Lepper
who crawls out from under the porch.
See these people standing over here?
These are basically the Leppers, and I'm basically
Eddie.
We don't have our own Jake Paul Team 10 house,
but I'm thinking after they're done using
this for promoting the movie, we can just
move into this house with some other YouTubers.
So I like that the windows are really nice
and boarded up.
That way when you're editing, you have no
sense of time.
Practically it's a set, so it's interchangeable.
You know this is the best line I've ever skipped.
You're getting the first look at Zac's brand
new house, which is cool.
Dakota's vlog is within my video.
We're going in.
I can't see anything.
Rule number 1: Do not touch the monsters.
Rule number 2: Don't lose me, and don't open
any doors without my permission, OK?
Got it?
OK.
Follow me up the stairs.
Come on.
Was there anyone behind you?
OK, this is all of us.
Don't split up, OK?
Welcome to the IT Experience.
This is Neibolt House in Hollywood, California.
This is where IT lives.
Once we go through this hallway it's up to
me to guide you out of here OK?
My name's Georgie.
Hiya Georgie!
Come on.
Through here.
Don't make them angry!
Be quiet!
And definitely do not look them in the eyes.
That's the worst possible thing you can do.
Come on.
Gather round the coffin.
Hey guys, is it too late to get our deposit
back?
Be quiet, don't make the clowns angry.
Get closer.
You guys have to get closer.
The coffin.
Say you're sorry.
Sorry!
Look out!
We've gotta go!
Come on!
Here, follow me.
Get out of there!
Get away from him!
Guys, over here.
...wonderful day.
Kill him.
Kill them all.
That's Dakota before he gets ready in the
morning.
We gotta go!
Come on!
Wait for me!
I think you have squatters in your house.
It's fine.
It's fine?
No!
Guys we gotta get out of here.
You!
Lead us out of here.
Heck no!
Come on.
We gotta get out of here.
You have to hurry.
Let's go!
Who wants to go next?
Let's just go through this one.
Come on, you did it once, you can do it again!
Let's go guys!
Oh, that wasn't--
Here, with me!
Come on!
Over here.
I don't think that's gonna come out.
We're gonna have to make a breakthrough, OK?
We're gonna go through the sewers.
Are you ready?
You have to stick together.
Follow me on three!
One!
Two!
THREE!
Come on!
This way!
Hurry, he's right behind you!
So what'd you think of the house tour Zac?
Buying.
Thank you guys for coming.
Luckily we all made it.
Bye.
And watch your back...
Bye Georgie!
I love you.
We are definitely buying that house.
No!
I think with a little bit of upkeep, I think
it's good to go.
Think of the views we could get living in there.
There's a lot of benefits to this house which
are really unexpected.
There was central air, there was closets...
there was one room that had three closets
in it!
That's great real estate.
That is pretty good real estate.
You're not gonna find something like that
around these parts.
You know?
It's just too expensive.
But this is a great deal, there's a little
roaches but what place doesn't have a roach
or two running around nowadays?
Just needs to be painted.
Black.
Yeah, like my soul.
It has I think plenty of rooms.
I think all the old occupants were really
nice, they kept the house in good shape.
It's a Craigslist house, what do you expect?
I really liked it.
I think you guys are gonna make great videos
in there.
I also like the bathtub full of intestines,
I hear it's a great exfoliant and moisturizer.
And it's a great space in LA, it's right in
all the action.
Right across the street is Pie Hole.
The Patron thing is somewhere over here.
The church of scientology is right across
the street.
Oh really?
Let's go get those free--
Oh good, another haunted house!
You guys were really happy about all the little
Georgies, but those little kids don't pay
rent, they're out of there.
As a horror house, it's excellent.
I didn't want to be there, I was terrified.
I clenched on to everything that I could so...
AJs a no-go on this one.
Hope you guys enjoyed that tour the IT Neibolt
House.
Let me know in the comments if you think that
we should buy this house and live in it.
Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week.
Ring that deathbell for notifications and
I'll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.
You know my favorite part of vlogging in the
hard rock cafe?
Being with me?